la problématique c'est que nos aînés
hospitalisés
vive énormément de problèmes de sommeil
on constate que nos infirmières ont peu
ou pas de connaissances à l'égard du
sommeil design hospitalisé
donc l'objectif de cette formation là de
cette étude le pardon c'était de donner
une formation dans le but de augmenté de
voir si ça pouvait augmenter le niveau
de connaissances des infirmières à
l'égard du sommeil design hospitalisés
et de voir si cette formation-là aura
aussi un impact sur l'administration des
hypnotiques communément appelé toute
médication pour dormir qu'on administre
aux besoins chez l'aîné et on voulait
par le fait même voir jusqu'à quel point
l oms quels sont les éléments qu'elle
utilise pour pallier aux problèmes de
sommeil ce qu'on constate ce qu'on
observe c'est qu'il ya une amélioration
significative du niveau de connaissances
des infirmières à l'égard du sommeil
après une formation trois heures est ce
qu'on constate aussi c'est que la
quantité d'hypnotiques de médication
pour dormir a diminué de façon
importante
lors de leur hospitalisation les
éléments qui ressortent pour pallier le
sommet ce qu'on constate c'est que les
infirmières sont beaucoup plus
sensibilisés à tous qui a défait
d'impact de l'environnement citalis au
sommet donc ce qu'elles vont mentionné
c'est la diminution du bruit
la diminution de la lumière et ce cri
mentionne en dernier recours c'est
l'administration des hypnotiques